whe
Allah
all
[Music]
Allah
alhamdulillah
[Music]
a
mean in the name of Allah the most
gracious the most
merciful Dr William Campbell Dr Zakir
NY Dr
mazus Dr Jamal
badawi Dr Samuel Naman and M Mr Sam
shamon distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen assalamu
Al peace and blessings of Almighty Allah
be upon all of
you on behalf of the organizers the
Islamic circle of North
America I say sabil Ahmed welcome all of
you to this unique
event a dialogue on the topic
the Quran the Bible in the light of
science again on behalf of Dr Campbell
Dr Zaki n Islamic circle of North
America this dialogue is being held in a
spirit of friendship understanding each
other's
viewpoints a brief introduction of os
activities Islamic circle of North
America the goal of Islamic circle of
North
America are to motivate Muslims to
perform their duty of being Witnesses
unto
mankind offering
educational training opportunities to
increase the Islamic knowledge and to
enhance the
character IAI is also active in opposing
immorality and oppression of all forms
supporting efforts for socioeconomic
Justice
civil liberties in the society
strengthening the bond of humanity by
serving all those in need anywhere in
the world with special focus on our
neighborhood across North America for
today's unique
dialogue the two main
moderators are Dr Muhammad nyak
representing Dr Zakir Nik and Dr Samuel
Nan representing Dr William
Campbell it is my duty to ensure a fair
and proper conduct of this
meeting therefore we request our
speakers as well as the audience to
maintain J decorum for a healthy
dialogue with that I would request Dr
Samuel Nan to give the introduction of
Dr William Campbell assalamu
alaykum thank you brother sabil Ahmed
it's a pleasure and honor to be here
with you this evening and uh first of
all I myself with a group of our
brothers and sisters from the Christian
background we really like to thank the
Islamic circle of North America and uh
the local people who have organized this
unique event they have done a great job
they have worked very hard and now we
have come to the last moment to be
here Dr William Campbell did his medical
work in Cleveland Ohio at Case Western
res University he worked for 20 years in
Morocco where he learned Arabic after 7
years in Tunisia he wrote his book
answering Dr morice
BK he is a convinced Christian who likes
to explain the inil or the gospel to
everyone at age 74 Dr Campbell is
retired with 10 grandchildren and we are
really thankful and we are really happy
to be here with you tonight thank
you
on behalf of the Islamic Research
Foundation I Dr Muhammad
Nik I'm pleased to be amongst you all
along with Dr
Zakir it's a pleasure to
be here for this unique event and have
the good pleasure of having Scholars
like Dr William Campbell Dr Jamal
badwi Dr mazas as well as my co-
colleague brother Dr Samuel
Naman you're with
us I on behalf of brother Samuel and
myself present the format for the
dialogue The Format has agreed and
decided fair by both our speakers is Dr
William Campbell would first address you
for 55 minutes on the topic the Quran
and the Bible in the light of
science then Dr Zakir n at the far
end would make his presentation for 55
minutes on the same
topic this would be followed by a
response session in which Dr Campbell
would respond to the matter presented by
Dr Zakir for 25 minutes followed by Dr
zaker to responding for 25 minutes to
the matter presented by Dr
Campbell lastly we would have the open
question and answer
session in which the audience May pose
questions to each speaker
alternately on the question marks
provided in the
auditorium after the
mics questions are handled we would
allow questions on index cards to be
provided by Volunteers in the
aisles and in the order selected at
random by the coordinators and the
advisers to each of the
speakers ladies and
gentlemen to address you today Dr
William
Campbell
greeting to Dr
Nike who came almost surely came the
farthest greeting to sabil Ahmed and
muhamed
Nike and greeting to the organizing
committee calling this the ultimate
dialogue is a bit of an
exaggeration but it is good
advertising and greetings to you the
audience I'd like to also bring
greetings in the name of Yahweh or
better known as Jehovah the great
Creator God who loves
us I wish to start by speaking about
words tonight we are going to speak
about the words of the Bible and the
words of the
Quran the scholars of modern Linguistics
tell us a word a phrase or sentence
means what it meant to the speaker and
the person a crowd of people
listening in the case of the Quran what
it meant to Muhammad and those listening
to him in the case of the Bible what it
meant to Moses or Jesus or those
listening to
them to check this we have the context
of all the usages in the Bible or the
quoran in addition there is the poetry
and letters of that Century for the
gospel the first century ad for the
Quran the first century of the HRA
if we are going to follow the truth we
may not make up new
meanings if we are seriously after truth
there are no permissible
lies here is an example of what I'm
talking
about going have the first slide
here this is talking about two
dictionaries that I have in my home one
from 1951 and
1991 in these two dictionaries the first
meaning Pig a young swine of either sex
is the
same the second meaning any swine or hog
any wild or D domestic swine it's the
same third the Flesh of swine pork is
the
same then the the meaning a person or
animal of piggish habits it's the same a
person who was
gluttonous and down here pouring metal
into a pig for pig iron is the same but
over here is a new meaning a police
officer you call the police officers
pigs all right the question
is in the Torah it says you can't eat
pigs well can I turn around and say oh
yes that means police officers you can't
eat police officers of course
not in the cor anal law says can't eat
pigs
can I translate it candy put police
officers no it's wrong it would be
stupid it would be lying actually
Muhammad did not mean police officers
Moses did not mean police officers we
may not have any new meanings we must
use the meanings known in the first
century ad for the Bible or that is for
the gospel and the first century of the
haer for the
Koran now let us look at what the Quran
is going says about
embryology oh sorry got the wrong
thing it has been said that the idea of
the embryo developing through stages is
a modern one and that the Quran is
anticipating modern embryology by
depicting differing
stages in a pamphlet entitled highlights
of human embryology by Keith L Moore Dr
Moore claims the realization that the
embryo develops in stages in the uterus
was not discussed or Illustrated until
the 15th
century we will weigh this claim by
considering the meaning of the Arabic
words used by the Quran and secondly by
examining the historical situation
leading up to and surrounding the
Quran we will start by looking at the
main words using the word alaka main
verses the Arabic word alaka in the
singular are alak as the collective
plural is used six
times in the Surah of the Resurrection
Al 7535 to39 we read was he man not a
drop of sperm ejaculated then he became
alaka and God shaped and formed and made
of him a pair the male and the female in
the Surah of the believer El mment 4067
it says he it is who created you from
dust then from a sperm drop then from a
leech like clot alaka then brings you
forth as a child that perhaps you may
understand in the S of the pilgrimage
elhadj 225 it says oh mankind if you
have doubt about the resurrection
consider that we have created you from
dust then from a drop of seed then from
a clot alaka then from a little lump of
Flesh shapely and
shapeless and finally the fullest
treatment is in the Sora of the
Believers
elmon 2312 to4 which reads verily we
created man from a product of wet Earth
then placed them as a drop of seed in a
safe lodging then we fashioned the drop
of clot ala and of the clot we fashioned
a lump and of the lump we fashion bones
and we clothe the bones with meat then
we produced it as another
creation and here you have the stages
according to the Cor
n sperm Al clot mud piece of meat Adam
bones and the fifth stage dressing the
bones with
muscles over the last 100 plus years
this word alaka has been translated as
follows there's 10 translations here I'm
not going to read them all three are in
French where it says
and or a clot of blood three versions
five versions are English where it's
either clot or leech-like
clot one version is in Indonesian at the
bottom there Sig palara lump of or clot
of blood and the last one is
fary hasta a clot of blood as every
reader who will study human reproduction
will realize there is no stage as a clot
during the formation of a fetus so this
so this is a very major scientific
problem in the dictionaries of were and
abdor the only meanings given for alaka
in this feminine singular are clot and
leech and in North Africa both of these
meanings are still
used many patients have come to me to
ask for a clot to be removed from their
throat and many women have come to me
and told me their period didn't come
when I say I'm sorry I can't give you
medicine to bring your period because I
believe that's a baby they would say
mael dim it's still blood so they were
understanding these ideas of the Quran
lastly we must consider the first verses
which came to Muhammad in Mecca these
are found in the 96th Surah called alak
clots from the very word that we're
studying in 9612 we read Proclaim in the
L of your lord who created created man
from
alak here the word is in the collective
plural plural this form of the word can
have other meanings because alak is also
the derived verbal noun of the verb
ala the verbal noun usually corresponds
to the jarand in English as in the
sentence swimming is
fun therefore we could expect it to mean
hanging or clinging or
adhering but the 10 translators listed
above have all used clot or congealed
blood in this verse
two in spite of the number and
qualification of these translators who
use the word clot the French Dr Morris
bukai has sharp words for them he writes
what is more likely to mislead the
inquiring reader is once again the
problem of
vocabulary the majority of translations
describe for example man's formation
from a blood clot a statement of this
kind is totally unacceptable to
scientist specializing in the
field this shows how great the
importance of an association between
linguistic and scientific knowledge is
when it comes to grasping the meaning of
quranic statements on
reproduction put in other words bukai is
saying nobody has translated the Quran
correctly until I Dr bukai came
along how does Dr bukai think that it
should be translated he proposes that
instead of clot the word alaka should be
translated as something which
clings which would refer to the fetus
being attached to the uterus through the
placenta
but as all you ladies who've been
pregnant now the thing which clings
doesn't stop its clinging to become
chewed meat it keeps on being the thing
which clings which is attached by the
placenta for8 and a half
months thirdly these verses say that the
chewed meat becomes bones and then the
bones are covered with muscle they give
the impression that first the skeleton
is formed and then it is closed with
flesh and Dr bukai knows perfectly well
that this is not not true the muscles
and the cartilage prec cursors of the
Bon start forming from the somite at the
same time at the end of the eighth week
there are only a few centers of oifc
started but the fetus is already able to
make muscular
movement in a personal letter from Dr
tww Sadler who's associate professor in
Embry in anotomy and the author of
langan's medical embryology Dr St Sadler
States at the eighth week post
fertilization the ribs would be
cartilagenous not bone and muscles would
be present also at this time oifc would
just
begin muscles would be capable of some
movement at 8
weeks it's always better to have two
witnesses so we shall see what Dr Keith
Moore has to say about the development
of bones and muscles in his book the
deop developing
human extracted from chapters 15 and 17
we find the following
information the SK skeletal system
develops from
mesoderm the limb muscles develop in the
limb buds that are derived from this
somatic
mesoderm we see that here on this
slide it's difficult perhaps to see but
there's the limb
bud and then here there's just a little
bit of
cartilage with the muscles around here
there's more cartilage and this is the
whole B the bones are formed and in the
form of bones but it's all cartilage no
bones
yet this second slide shows how it forms
here's a here's the cartilage now just
the bone is looks like cartilage and
then it starts to have some calcium
deposited and then it starts to have
oifc and Bone
form
as the bone models form
sorry I want to go back to this as the
bone models form myoblasts develop a
large muscle mass in each limb Bud
separating into extensor and flexor
muscles in other words the limb muscles
develop simultaneously from the mezen
Kim surrounding the developing bones so
there's the cartilage and here are the
muscles developing around the cartilage
during a personal conversation with Dr
Moore I showed him Dr Sadler's statement
and he agreed that it was absolutely
valid conclusion Dr Sadler and Dr Moore
agreed there is no time when calcified
Bones have been formed and then the
muscles are placed around them the
muscles are there several weeks before
there are calcified bones rather than
being added around previously formed
bones as the Coran States the Coran is
in complete error here the problems are
far from being
solved let us will return to
alaka Dr Moore also has a suggestion he
says another verse in the Quran refers
to the leech-like appearance and the
chewed like stages of human development
from this definition Dr Moore has gone
ahead to propose that A 233 day a 23-day
embryo 3 mm long
that's an eighth of an inch I can hardly
put my fingers that close together
without
touching this is carnegi stage 10 shown
on the inside cover of Morris's
book this is the
beginning and here's the sperm entering
the egg so that's stage one comes down
here to Stage six in the second
week and here is the third week and
there it's cage 10 and here is day
23 and this is what Dr Moore wants to
say looks like a
leech if we look further though and look
at the X-ray here's day 22 when the bone
backbone is still open and when we look
at day 23 the backbone is open there and
it's open there and the head is wide
open it doesn't look like a leech at
all and if you keep on and this this is
a diagram of it the head is open the
rostral
neuropore and finally this diagram shows
there's the there is the the 20-day
embryo it's got a Yol saac it's got an
umbilicus it doesn't look like a leech
at
all the problem the great problem with
these new definitions for the word alaka
is that no confirming examples have been
provided from the Arab Arabic Ed in the
C surrounding the haera the only way to
establish the meaning of the word is by
usage the only way to establish whether
the singular form alaka can mean a 3mm
embryo or the thing that clings is to
bring sentences demonstrating this usage
from the literature of the Arabs of
Mecca and Madina close to the time of
Muhammad especially from the language of
the
Kash this will not be an easy task
because much work has already been done
on the clear AR Arabic of the
ques the early Muslims understood
intuitively the need to know exactly
what the quranic words mean and for this
reason they made comprehensive studies
of their language and poetry ham abubakr
former Rector of the main mosque in
Paris brought up this subject at a
conference on the one God in monilia in
1985 he posed the question to the
audience has the comprehension of the
text of the Quran known at the time of
Muhammad remains stable and his answer
was ancient poetry shows that it
has we can only only conclude if the
verses which bring spiritual comfort and
hope to Muslims have remained stable
then the scientific statements embedded
in those verses must also be accepted as
stable unless new evidence can be
brought
forward this is especially important
since some of the verses say that this
information is a sign but The Sur of the
believer as we saw above says he is he
it is who created you from dust then
from a sperm drop then from a clot alaka
that perhaps you may understand and in
the Sur of the pilgrimage he said oh
mankind if you have doubt about the
resurrection
consider therefore the question must be
as asked if it was a clear sign to the
men and women of Mecca and Medina what
did they understand from the word alaka
which would lead them to to Faith in the
Resurrection the
answer we are going to examine the
historical situation leading up to the
time of Muhammad to see what Muhammad
and his people believed about
embryology we will start with
hypocrates according to the best
evidence he was born on the Greek island
of Co in 460
BC and he has stages his stages are as
follows
the sperm is a product which comes from
the whole body of each parent weak sperm
coming from the weak parts and strong
sperm from the strong parts then he goes
ahead and talks about the coagulation of
the mother's blood the seed embryo then
is contained in a membrane moreover it
grows because of its mother's blood
which descends to the womb for once a
woman conceives she ceases to
menstrate then about
flesh he says at this stage with The
Descent and coagulation of the mother's
blood flesh begins to form with the be
formed with the unbel likeus and lastly
bones he says as the flesh grows it is
formed into distinct members by breath
the bones grow hard like a and send out
branches like a
tree next week we will look at
Aristotle in his B book on the
generation of animals sometime about 350
BC he gives his stages of
embryology and he talks about first
semen and menstrual blood or
catamenia in this section Aristotle
speaks of the male semen as being in a
pure state it follows that what the
female would contribute to the seen of
the male would be material for the seen
to work on in other words the semen
clots the menstrual blood then he goes
to flesh he says nature forms this from
the purest material the Flesh and from
the residue thereof it forms
bones and lastly around the flesh around
the bones and attached to them by Thin
fibrous bands grow the fleshly parts
clearly the Quran follows this exactly
sperm clotting the menstrual flood which
forms meat then the bones are formed and
lastly around SP the bones grow the
fleshly
parts next we will consider Indian
medicine the in the opinion of sharaka
and 123 ad and sus Ruta is that both the
male and female contributed seed the
secretion of the male is called the
sucra SEMA the secretion of the woman is
called arar sonita blood and it is
derived from the blood by way of food by
way of blood here we see that in the
medicine of India They too had the idea
that the child was formed from seman and
blood now we shall look at Galen Galen
was born in 131 ad in pergam nor modern
berma and
turkey Galen says on seman the substance
from which the fetus is formed is not
merely menstrual blood as Aristotle
maintained but menstral blood plus the
two
semens the Quran agrees with galin here
when it says in Surah 7 62 we created
man from a drop of mingled
sperm now we'll look at the galin
stages Galen also taught that the embryo
developed in stages the first is that in
which the form of the semen
prevails the next stage is when it has
been filled with blood and heart and
brain and liver are still unarticulated
and unshaped this is the period that
hippocrite Hippocrates called
fetus the the quranic Surah 225 reflects
this saying then out of a morsel of
Flesh partly formed and partly
unformed and now the third period of
gestation has
come this thus it it nature caused flesh
to grow on and around all the
bones we saw above that the Quran agrees
with this in Sora 2314 where it says and
we clothe the bones with meat the fourth
and final period
sorry the fourth and final period is at
the stage when all the parts of the in
the limbs have been
differentiated galin was so important in
medicine that just about the time of the
hazra four leading medical men in
Alexandria Egypt decided to form a
medical school using 16 books of galin
as the basis of the studies this
considered continued up to and including
the 13th
century we must now ask ourselves what
was the political economic and medical
situation in Arabia at the time of
Muhammad from the hadramout in Yen the
Caravans of the spa spice trade passed
North through Mecca and Medina and then
reached into all of Europe in North
Arabia in about 500 AD the ranids took
over and by
528 they controlled the Syrian desert
over to the outskirts of medana Syriac a
form of Aramaic related to Arabic was
their official language as early as 463
the Jews translated the Torah in Old
Testament from Hebrew into syak the
British museum has a copy this made it
available to the rasan who were
Christians and to the Jewish tribes in
Arabia during this time sergia SAS
who died in can Constantinople in
536 one of the earliest and greatest
translators from Greek into syc
translated various works on medicine
including 26 works of
galin this made them available in the
Kingdom of kasu 1 in Persia into the
rassan tribe whose influence extended to
the outskirts of
Madina kasu one Arabic kisra King of
Persia was known as kasu the
great his troops conquered areas as far
away as Yemen and he also loved learning
and started several
schools the school of jundishapur became
during kasu 1's long reign of 48 years
the greatest intellectual center of the
time within its walls Greek Jewish
nestorian Persian and Hindu thought and
experience were freely
exchanged teaching was done largely in
syak from sric translations of Greek
texts this meant that Aristotle
Hippocrates and galin were readily
available when the medical school at
jundishapur was operating during his
Reign The Next Step was that the
Conquering Arabs compelled the
nestorians to translate their Syriac
texts of Greek medicine into Arabic the
translation from Syriac to Arabic was
easy as the two languages had the same
grammar concering the local medical
situation during Muhammad's life we know
there were Physicians living in Arabia
during this period harith Ben Kad was
the best educated physician trained in
The Healing Arts he was born about the
middle of the 6th Century at thif in the
tribe of bani thak he traveled through
Yemen and then Persia where he received
his education in the medical Sciences at
the great Medical School of jundi shapur
and thus was intimately acquainted with
the medical teachings of Aristotle
Hippocrates and Galen having completed
his studies he practiced as a physician
in Persia and during this time he was
called to the court of King hosu with
whom he had a long
conversation he came back to Arabia
about the beginning of Islam and settled
down at
Ty while there Abu a king of Yemen came
to see him in con connection with a
certain disease and on being cured
rewarded him with much money and a slave
girl though harith Ben Kad did not write
any book on medicine
his views on many medical problems are
preser preserved in his conversation
withu about the eye he says that is
constituted of fat which is the white
part about the and then the second is
constituted with water which is the
black part and of wind which constitutes
the eyesight well these things we know
to be wrong now but this was Greek
thought all this goes to show the
acquaintance of Hari with the Greek
doctors summarizing the situation in a
few words in his book de medine Arab Dr
Lucian ler writes harith Ben kada
studied medicine at jandi shapur and
Muhammad owed to harth a part of his
medical knowledge thus with with the
thus with the one as well as the other
we easily recognize the traces of Greek
medicine sometimes mamama treated the
sick but in the difficult cases he would
send the patients to
harith
another educated man person around
Muhammad was Nader B harith not related
to the doctor he was a karashite and
cousin of Muhammad and had also visited
the court of hu he had learned Persian
and music which he introduced Among The
KES at at
Mecca however he was not sympathetic to
Muhammad mocking some of the stories in
the Quran Muhammad never forgave him for
this and when he was taken prisoner at
the Battle of Bader he caused him to to
be put to death in summary we see that
one Arabs living in Mecca and Medina in
600 had political and economic relations
with people from Ethiopia Yemen Persia
and
Byzantine a cousin of Muhammad knew
Persian well enough to do his musical
studies in it three the rassan tribe
which ruled the Syrian desert over to
the gates of Medina used syak one of the
the main languages used to teach
medicine in jundi shapur is their
official language an ill king of Yemen
came to thif to consult The Physician
harith Ben kada who had been trained
where at jundi shapur the best medical
school in that world and to whom
Muhammad sometimes sent patients five
during Muhammad's lifetime a new medical
school was established in Alexandria
using the 16 books of Galen as their
texts this all shows that there was
ample opportunity for Muhammad and the
people around him to have heard of the
embryological theories of Aristotle
Hippocrates and galin when they went to
seek treatment from harth Ben colada and
other local doctors thus when the Quran
says in the late mechur of the believer
4067 he it is who created you from dust
then from a sperm drop then from a
leech-like clot that perhaps you may
understand and then in the S of the
pilgrimage oh mankind if you have doubt
about the resurrection ction consider
what we have created that we have
created you from dust it is correct for
us to ask again what were they to
understand what were they to
consider and here are the quranic stages
again
notak CL mud piece of meat Adam bones
and five dressing the bones with muscles
the answer is very clear they were
understanding and considering that which
was common knowledge the embryological
stages is taught by the Greek
Physicians I don't mean that Muhammad's
listeners all knew the names of the
Greek Physicians but they knew the
embryological stages of the Greek
Physicians they believed that the male
sperm mixed with a female menstrual
blood to cause it to clot and this be
this became the baby two they believed
there was a time when the fetus was
formed and unformed three they believed
the bones formed first and then were
covered with muscle Allah was using that
common knowledge as a sign encouraging
the listeners and readers to turn to him
the trouble is that this common
knowledge was and is not
true Arab Physicians after
Muhammad we must now look at two
well-known Physicians from the period
after Muhammad obviously they had no
effect on the Quran but they
demonstrated that faith in the
embryological ideas of Aristotle
hypocrates and galin continued among the
Arabs right up to the
1600s if the correct translation of
alaka is Le like substance as modern
Muslims like shabir Ali claim there is
no place where these post koranic
doctors said so in fact it's just the
opposite the ideas of these Greek
Physicians were being used to explain
the Quan and the Coran was quoted to
Enlighten the meaning of the Greek
Physicians the human being takes its
origin from two this is speaking about
even aena or Aisa the human human being
takes its origin from two things the
male sperm which plays the part of
factor the female sperm first part of
the menstrual blood which provides the
matter thus we see that iuo gave the
female Sean exactly the same role that
Aristotle had assigned to the menstrual
blood it is difficult to overstate the
importance of iena as a scientific and
philosophical Authority for the
premodern
Europeans then we're going to look at
Ian cim Al
jaia Ian cim took full advantage of the
agreement between quranic
Revelation and Greek
medicine this is not very clear
probably but the hypocrates is in
purplish and the quoran is in bold Type
green and the hadit is in purple and
common terries are in red and his own
thoughts in sort of a blue
green so it starts out he's giving he
says hypocrates said in the third
chapter of kab
a a
a the semen is contained in a membrane
and it grows because of the blood of its
mother which descends to the womb some
membranes are formed at the beginning
others after the second month and others
in the third month and this phrase about
the blood descending to the womb we saw
it when we looked at hypocrates slide
that is why God said here the Quan is
mentioned he creates you in the womb of
your mothers by one formation after
another in three darknesses that's Quan
9396 then he gives his own ideas since
each of these membranes has its own
darkness when god mentioned the stages
of creation and transformation from one
state to another He also mentioned the
darknesses of the membranes most
commentators explain and here are the
words of the commentators it is the
darkness of the belly and the Darkness
of the womb and the Darkness of the
placenta in a second example we
read H hypocrates said the mouth opens
up spontaneously and the nose and ears
are formed from the flesh the ears are
opened and the eyes which are filled
with a clear
liquid the prophet used to say I worship
Him who made my face and formed it and
open my hearing and eyesight and so so
forth here we look at hypocrates again
and there in the second stage is the
same thing we just read IIM is quoting
hypocrit hypocrates and speaks of the
mother's blood descends around the
membrane he could do this as we have
seen because the educated people of
Muhammad's time were familiar with Greek
medicine however what is important for
us here today to realize is
that there is no place where the Quran
corrected Greek medicine there is no
place where even Kim was shouting hey
you guys you've got it this all wrong
the correct meaning of alaka is that
which clings or leech like substance on
the contrary Ian cim was demonstrating
the agreement between the Quran and the
Greek medicine their agreement in error
a Final witness is the commentary of BWI
in 1200
ad here we have the commentary we have
the the the we have the Coran here we
have his car his commentary and here
it's been translated and he says then
from alaka a piece of solid blood is his
explanation of alaka alaka is underlined
that's from the Quan and here's his
explanation a piece of solid blood then
he goes on then from a piece of meat
from the Quan a piece of meat originally
as much as can be chewed and so
forth
as I mentioned at the beginning of this
study it has been said that the idea of
the embryo developing through stages is
a modern one and that the Quran is
anticipating mod modern embryology by
depicting differing stages yet we have
seen that Aristotle hypocrates the
Indians and gayin have all discussed the
stages of embryological development
during the thousand years before the the
Quran and after the coming of the Quran
the account of the different stages as
described by the Quran and the Greek
doctors was carried on in the teachings
of aisna and
IIM and is essentially the same as that
taught by Galen and those preceding him
compering concerning the bone stage it's
clear as Dr Moore demonstrated so
capably in his textbook that muscles
start forming from the somites at the
same time as the cartilage models of the
bones there's no bone stage where
there's a skeleton sitting here and then
and then the the the muscles are
plastered around
it it is equally clear that alaka in the
Quran means clot and that The KES who
heard Muhammad speaking understood him
to be referring to the menstrual blood
as the female contribution to the
developing baby therefore we can
conclude that during all these years the
quranic verses on
embryology saying that man is Created
from a drop of sperm which Kims a clot
were in perfect Accord with the science
of the first century of the HRA of the
time of the Quran but wouldn't compared
with the modern science of the 20th
century hypocrates is in error Aristotle
is in error Galan is an error and the K
Coran is an error they are all in
serious
error
now we're going to look a little bit
about
Moonlight does the Quan state that the
moon gives off reflected light from the
sun before this was common
knowledge in the Sora of Noah
71516 it says see ye not how Allah has
created the seven H Heavens one above
another and made the moon a light no in
their midst and made the Sun as a lamp
SE
the Moon is called a light Arabic n and
the Sun a lamp C some Muslims claim that
since the Quran uses different words
speaking from about the light of the sun
and the light of the Moon it reveals
that the sun is a source of light while
the moon only reflects light this claim
is implied very strongly by shabir Ali
in his booklet science in the Quan and
stated clearly by Dr Zakir Nike in his
video is the Quan God word as you will
now see
clearly the light that we
have the light that we obtain from the
Moon where where does it come from so he
will tell me that previously we thought
that the light of the moon was its own
light but today after science Advanced
we have come to know that the light of
the moon is not its own light but it's a
reflected light of the
sun I will ask him a
question that it is mentioned in this
Quran in Surah Alan chapter number 25
verse number 16 one blessed is he who
has created the constellations and
placed there in a lamp and a
moon which has reflected
light the Arabic word for moon
isar and the light described there is M
which is borrowed light or n which is a
reflection of light the Quran mentions
that the light of the moon is reflected
light you say you discovered it today
how come it's mentioned in the Quran
1,400 years
ago he will pause for a time he won't
reply immediately and then may say maybe
maybe it's a
fluk I don't agree with him for
S near the end of the video we heard Dr
Nike explain the Arabic word for moon is
Kamar and the light described there is
moir which is borrowed light or no which
is a reflection of light
please do not forget what he said munir
is borrowed light and nor is reflected
light not only is this claimed to be a
statement in keeping with scientific
truth but it is also claimed to be
scientifically miraculous since this was
supposedly only discovered relatively
recently it is correct that the moon
does not emit its own light but only
reflects the light of the Sun but this
was known already almost a thousand
years before
Muhammad Aristotle and about 360 BC
discussed knowing that the Earth was
round by its shadow on the moon he could
only speak of the Earth's Shadow AC
crossing the moon if he knew that
Moonlight is reflected light if you
still insist that this is a miracle of
scientific knowledge then we must ask
ourselves do the quranic words
themselves support this claim SJ first
we shall look at SJ in Sora Noah which
was read above in s Al foran 27
2561 it is simply lamp referring to the
sun in Surah 7813 Siran Wan means a
dazzling lamp again indicating the Sun
the words N and moir come from the same
Arabic
word root the word moir is used six
times in the Quran four times Sur Imran
3184 alhaj 228 lukman 3120 and fater
3535 it is the phrase kab munir which YF
Ali translate as a book of Enlightenment
and P Pall uses the scripture giving
light clearly this indicates a book
which is radiating the light of
knowledge nothing about reflection
nor it says in Surah no 7116 and unas
105 that Allah made the light the moon a
light thus we find that the Quran says
that the Moon is a light
and it never says that the moon reflects
light moreover in other verses the Quran
says that Allah is a no a light Surah
2435 one of the most beautiful passages
in the Quran reads Allah is the light
nor of the heavens and the Earth the
parable of his light is as if there was
a niche a niche and within it a lamp the
lamp enclosed Ed in glass the glass as
it were a brilliant star and so forth
thus we see that the word n is used for
both the moon and a are we going to say
that Allah gives off reflected light I
think not but if you continue to insist
that no used for the moon means borrowed
or reflected light and we saw above that
Allah is the light nor of the heavens
and the Earth what is the source of this
light sir of which Allah is only a
reflection think about
if Allah is named nor or reflected light
who or what is the
sirash well the Quran tells us who the
sirash is but the answer will shock you
in Surah alab 33 4546 we find oh Prophet
truly we have sent thee as a witness a
bearer of glad tidings and a Warner and
as a lamp spreading light here it says
in Muhammad is the lamp spreading light
in Arabic it is what
San linguistically and spiritually this
is the end of the discussion
linguistically sir and the adjective
moir are used together for the same
shining thing the person
Muhammad it's clear moir does not mean
reflected light in this verse or in any
other verse it means shining the people
of Muhammad's time understood that the
moon was shining and they were right
just as the people of Moses time
understood that the sun was the greater
light and the moon the Lesser light and
they were
right but if you insist the Arabic words
N and munir mean reflected light then
based on the use of these words in the
Quran Muhammad is like the sun and Allah
is like the moon does Dr Nike really
want to say that Muhammad is the source
of light and Allah is only his
reflection why are these so-called
scientific claims made which no muslim
can support if he makes a serious study
of his own Quan in a dialogue like
tonight it makes honest discussion very
difficult almost
impossible let us go on and look at the
water
cycle some Muslims and other author some
Muslim authors claim that the Quran
shows pre-scientific knowledge of water
cycle what is the water
cycle here in this slide you see four
steps the first step is evaporation the
water evaporates from the Seas and the
Earth second step it becomes clouds
third step it gives rain and fourth this
rain causes the plants to grow this is
all very
straightforward and everybody knows two
three and four even if they live in a
town they know the clouds come and rain
comes and their flowers
grow but what about step one the
evaporation you can't see it it's
difficult and the Quran does not have
step one
now we're going to look at a prophet
from the Bible a prophet from 700
BC Prophet
Amos and he
writes he who made the pleades and Orion
who turns black Blackness Into Dawn and
darkness darkest darkens day into
night and then who calls off for the
Waters of the the sea stage one and
pours them out over the face of the land
stage three the Lord Yahweh is his
name and what one other
Prophet is uh
job in 36
2628 at least a thousand years before
the
HRA he says how great is God beyond our
understanding the number of his years is
past finding out stage one he draws up
the drops of water which distill from
the Mist as rain that's stage three and
then the clouds are mentioned stage true
stage two which pour down their moisture
and abundant showers fall on
mankind so here in the Bible this
difficult stage one is there from more
than a thousand years before the Koran